okay welcome to the reason live stream
I'm Zach Weissmuller I am here with my
colleague Nick Gillespie and today we're
going to do something a little different
in the past we've been uh bringing on a
guest to talk through a topic today it's
just going to be me and Nick and we're
going to go through some documents that
have been the Talk of the Town at least
if you happen to be on Twitter and those
are what have become known as the
Twitter files which were the first
installment was dropped on Twitter by
Matt taibi The Independent journalist
formerly of Rolling Stone uh in the
series and then a series of Twitter
threads that amounted to internal
documents uh from Twitter particularly
around the time of the suspension of
Donald Trump but also in the time of
covid and things being labeled as
medical misinformation
these documents just kind of give some
insight as to what the internal
decision-making processes were so we're
going to go through some of those
documents and just talk about you know
what we think are important about them
um what they might have to say about the
state of free speech in America and
online and just the future of social
media uh but before we get into that uh
it's probably worth talking just a
little bit about why this is something
even worth discussing I mean
Twitter is a fairly large social media
site but it's by you know by no means
the biggest in the United States it's
fairly influential because it's a kind
of Nexus of political discourse
um famously you know Donald Trump's uh
Twitter was a place where you could get
these unfiltered thoughts until uh he
was taken down but I'm curious to just
throw that question to you first Nick
why does Twitter and what Matt and what
happens on it and you know who runs it
and what rules govern it you know matter
to us well you know I I think uh for you
know over a dozen years now Twitter has
been like this massive supplemental
space where a lot of really interesting
stuff has gone on uh you know from uh
the Arab Spring to kind of uh uh you
know in its early years Twitter was
given a lot of credit for kind of
revitalizing mass media uh because
people would watch the Oscars or the
Emmys or the Grammys or the NHL All-Star
Game and simultaneously kind of critique
it and have a running dialogue it was
really you know Twitter is a great
platform uh that you know I've spent way
too much time on but uh you know since
it started or since I joined in January
2009
um but I do that because it's it's
interesting and exciting more
specifically Twitter in terms of
politics in the US and media in the US
especially is the place where
politicians and journalists go
um in order to have you know their kind
of circle jerks and things like that so
what's going on in Twitter matters a
huge amount but it's also you know
Twitter you know it's not just got the
the little bird thing but it's also kind
of the canary in the coal mine of the
coming restrictions and possible uh
restrictions and regulations on all
kinds of I don't even want to say social
media anymore I just want to say like
you know online
um platforms and things like that
Twitter is you know uh is is that the
the Spear of the tip or the tip of the
spear when it comes to wanting to get
rid of section 230
et cetera Elon Musk is also and you know
just to kind of get many of the grand
teams we'll be talking about in the next
hour out there uh Elon Musk is the
billionaire he's not the billionaire we
want maybe but he's the billionaire we
need with Donald Trump receding
um you know we need it's as if we need a
narcissistic solipsistic uh main
character syndrome-driven billionaire to
suck up all the oxygen and it's Elon
Musk um you know right now what's going
on in Twitter is you know it's it's an
important conversation and then the
other thing I'll shut up after this what
the Twitter files have shown so far I
think and I know that you you know
broadly agree with me is you know they
um we have to read them carefully we
have to understand that Elon Musk is
releasing them to people that he picked
forcing them to talk about them on his
platform
et cetera you know those are all caveats
that are important to keep in mind but
they are also giving us an un
unprecedented glimpse into how media
companies social media companies operate
with inside themselves with political
threats coming at them Etc like this
this is a tutorial in how social media
and the internet which is supposed to be
free of all the kind of meat space
encumbrances of old media and of
political power this is how it operates
in in kind of cyberspace so there's a
lot to talk about yeah and you know
what's interesting to me about Twitter
uh in particular is that it is such
um for a long time it felt like a very
unmediated space you know you could go
into the replies of some major celebrity
and uh you know quote-unquote ratio them
with a witty comment it's kind of like
the the demo it was the great leveler
yeah it's yeah you know it turned
everybody into Ozymandias you know I I
uh however many years ago this was I
remember when Bill uh Cosby was mounting
his comeback tour and his Twitter
account said hey you know like you know
I was famous for wearing sweaters on The
Cosby Show post your favorite member of
me in a sweater on The Cosby Show and
instantly got flooded with all the you
know rape jokes Etc so much so he closed
his account and that was a huge Tipping
Point for him like you know pulling out
of a comeback and you know legal actions
starting against it it's a great leveler
yeah it kind of exemplifies this idea
that
um I put out uh kind of the dawn of the
the new decade I did a kind of end of
decade video called uh it was a
retrospective looking at the 2010s and I
called it you know the 2010s
um the death of the media Gatekeepers
um and uh that was about uh you know my
my thesis there and I'll play just a
short clip from that at least but my uh
thesis there is that the kind of one of
the most important big picture takeaways
from that decade was
um the fact that the old Gatekeepers
were losing their power and it's not
that there's you know I think what we're
seeing now is not necessarily that
there's no Gatekeepers but there's new
Gatekeepers kind of jockeying to uh fill
that position so let me just uh Play a
clip from that and then we can talk
about that that big picture uh some some
more of these uh you know big Concepts
and then drill down into the Twitter
files great what did the 2010s add up to
Media theorist Marshall mcluhan who
coined the Axiom the medium is the
message argued that history's prime
mover isn't the great leader or great
thinker but ever-changing Communications
Technologies in the 1960s mcluhan
identified our current Epoch as the
electric age in which circuit-based
media gave rise to what he termed the
global village for the first time in
history the entire world could follow a
single event mcloone predicted that this
electric Global Village would undo both
the national homogeneity and personal
individuality engendered by print
Reviving our more fractured and tribal
past we're retribalizing involuntarily
we're getting rid of individualism we're
more concerned with what the group knows
a feeling as it does of acting with it
and as the electric age has evolved into
the digital age with its cheap Limitless
replicability this re-tribalization has
accelerated in the 2010s which is why
the past decade has both created
opportunities and dangers for the
libertarian and liberal worldviews
so I I don't know how you feel about uh
Marshall mcluhan I find him to be one of
these thinkers who is um fascinating has
a lot of great insights at times uh
inscrutable
um at other times seems to be like
exactly predicting some of what uh has
unfolded but uh you know I I do think
that what um has happened here is that
uh and and I bring up examples in the
video of like you know Obama being one
example of he uh was not the people
forget some people might forget this but
he was not the establishment candidate
um it was Hillary Clinton and he was
able to leverage social media to his
Advantage I was that was a huge
um Advantage for Obama and then you know
obviously Trump took it to a different
level we had disruptors like Andrew
Breitbart and James O'Keefe who are you
know kind of the exemplars of like the
New Media
um just like going gorilla style and
um posting stuff right on the internet
that would go huge and like disrupt the
conversation and so I think that
happened
um and then kind of culminating in
Donald Trump uh and then there was a
kind of reaction that's now happening to
kind of try to re-constitute
um some semblance of what that that
disrupted I mean I think you know one of
the ways I I reach for this and this
actually is part of mcluhan's discourse
uh one of his early books was called the
Gutenberg Galaxy you know and it's about
to have the printing press you know
obviously fundamentally change things
but you know the the printing press
allowed the Reformation to happen for
you know Martin Luther to get around The
Gatekeepers of the Catholic Church
um and what we're witnessing now which
is worth thinking about is a Counter
Reformation you know the Catholic Church
wasn't like ah you know what like uh
people can print their own Bibles with
the books in their own order leaving
some things out putting it in the
vernacular of you know every language in
Europe or on the planet well you know
while we had a good run like no they you
know they they created the uh you know
things like the Inquisition and the
Jesuits and like they mounted a
Counter-Strike to try and Claw back as
much power in centralization as they
could semi-successful Protestant said it
too but like we are in you know if if we
consider the internet as becoming a mass
phenomenon only towards the end of the
90s when the World Wide Web you know
which is laid on top of the internet
made
um you know made the internet a true
Mass medium or or the web was the first
thing you know we're only you know 15 20
years into this process
um and you know Gatekeepers are pissed
you know TV networks and uh you know
Legacy Media printed you know print
institutions as well as political power
don't take this stuff lightly
um and you know that's I think is a good
frame to think about what's going on we
are witnessing an attempt by old
institutions political commercial
cultural to uh kind of gain power back
but we're also witnessing the morphing
of social media you know because one of
the things that is I think should be
disturbing to people about the Twitter
files which are important you know it
we'll talk about people who want to just
say nothing's going on here but it's
showing how Twitter and you know new
forms of of media are also working to
control the discourse in very specific
often you know kind of implicit ways so
yeah the the and um the the you know you
mentioned the idea that
um you know it's it's been somewhat
dismissed by a certain journalists um
and analysts as this this doesn't really
matter
um when when we're well let me actually
hearken on one point you brought up
there about
um you know this this environment that
we're in now if if we take the mcluhan
frame seriously you know we moved from
kind of spoken word to written word to
printing press which you know uh was uh
enabled the uh reformation and
um and and now we're moving into the
digital we're in the digital age and
yeah we're we're even past it in a sense
because everything is digitized and
there is Simon simultaneous
that real-time simultaneous multi-uh
directional communication the globe you
know and it's interesting when you think
about people like mcluhan people like
Stuart brand I mean people who were
conceptualizing the Earth as a unit
rather than talking about like warring
factions on this planet or something now
the planet is the unit we're way past
that um you know because
yeah and it's it's if you know if the
medium is the message you know one of
the messages of the digital media might
be you know this kind of infinite
um both replicability and
customizability so uh in terms of
Gatekeepers there's an ability to for
the individual to have a lot more say in
selecting the get because you're still
going to want to have some someone you
know nobody can deal with you know all
the information that is out there uh you
need somebody to whittle it down for you
but there's just a lot more choice and
optionality of of who that's going to be
or or what that's going to be if if you
choose to go uh say you're going to do
it algorithmically or something like
that
um we'll probably get a little bit more
into that later but uh The Gatekeepers
that uh Elon Musk chose to
um release this information where uh
Matt taibi and then Barry Weiss and
Michael schellenberger who we've had on
this stream before and let's just go
through uh some of the material here
um kind of in in the order it was
released this was December 2nd was the
first uh kind of dump that that meant
taibi made and it focused largely on the
hunter Biden laptop which uh Twitter
um throttled the well they actually says
yeah they didn't throttle it they banned
mentioning or linking to that or I guess
you know linking to that story that's
right and they also froze the New York
posts account for more than a week uh
the the outlet that originally reported
on this of course we all know the Hacked
material turned out to be legitimate
um and uh what what Matt taibi is
putting forth here based on what the
material that he saw is that that both
political parties had access to people
within Twitter where they could just you
know send an email and say hey take a
look at this thing take a look at this
tweet that it's it's misinformation or
it's violating your terms of service and
there would be some sort of you know it
didn't guarantee that something was
going to get taken down but it would
kind of fast track getting something
looked at so both parties had this uh he
points out that when you look at the
donorship of Twitter staff it excuse you
know
almost exclusively uh Democrat so that
implies that you know this process is
going to kind of inherently favor one
side over another just because there's
going to be a lot more sympathy and
points of contact
UM and he also points out which I
highlighted here and I think is
important
um for us to note is that there's no
evidence that I've seen of any
government involvement in the laptop
story so this was all yeah internal
decision making uh I'll I'll be at you
know there was input coming from you
know political forces uh on the outside
uh it was made the decision was made at
the highest levels of the company but
apparently without the knowledge of CEO
Jack Dorsey
um and uh hacking was the initial excuse
one employee told him but within a few
hours pretty much everyone realized that
wasn't going to hold but no one had the
guts to reverse it so so what uh
do you what can we learn from kind of
this first thread on the way the hunter
Biden story was was handled I mean a
couple of things stand out first it's
it's good that we you know it isn't like
the government said don't do this uh and
like you know they simply were reacting
to a threat you know or a direct threat
or a request by the government I suppose
or the federal government but what's
troubling is you recognize and you know
as Zach years ago we did a uh video
together about uh Michelle Foucault and
his thinking and you know people like
Foucault people like
um Jon Stewart Mill and whatnot you know
stress that like control doesn't operate
at the point of you know a whip or a
handcuff or a lashing or something like
that people internalize it and what you
see in you know in this Spate of Twitter
files I think is partly mid management
or upper management at Twitter saying
you know what we we need to control this
like they're anticipating what might be
asked of them or they they're carrying
government water you know in in a sense
or or sensorial water buckets uh
themselves so that's disturbing company
culture matters also the fact that Jack
Dorsey who later testified in Congress
saying you know that us cutting you know
deleting uh you know the Tweet or making
it impossible to to link to that story
was a mistake
um you know that you know company
culture matters
um and this seems reminiscent of what a
lot of people talk about at a lot of
social media companies that whoever the
founders are and whoever is technically
in charge there is a crop of people who
actually run the company day to day who
have a vision that might be very
distinct from you know the Free Speech
fantasies or the let it rip kind of
libertarianism of somebody like a Jack
Dorsey or Elon Musk or a Mark Zuckerberg
Etc
yeah and I I think that it's really
important to uh uh mention all right I
think it's really important to
acknowledge that the kind of maximalist
version of like how nefarious this might
have been is not true that there's not
some sort of um you know government-led
conspiracy to do this that this was Lar
gely
um kind of the result of a what looks to
me like a flawed internal bureaucratic
process yeah and that that's the great
thing about something like the Twitter
files uh you know Elon Musk the new
management is kind of you know dumping
this to make the old management look bad
but we as a result we the
um consumers uh through Matt taibi's
work get some transparency and all this
and and that's good we should be
scrutinizing these companies you know
that that's the role that's supposed to
be the role of uh of the fourth estate
and also just you know that's one of the
promises I'm old enough to you know I
started a reason in 93 as the internet
was really booming and you know this was
one of the promises of digital culture
of cyberspace or whatever you wanted to
call it was that transparency was coming
whether you liked it or not and we've
seen that you know it was great that you
know when when groups like Wikipedia uh
or excuse me not Wikipedia well
Wikipedia is a is its own thing but
Wikileaks uh and later in the Arts uh or
the late uh yeah I guess late Arts early
teens rather you know when Edward
Snowden dumped stuff people like uh you
know Bradley Chelsea Manning reality
winner
um you know transparency is much more
widespread now it is rarely transparency
that is voluntarily enacted you know
it's like we live in an age of
transparency but it's mostly Force so
that's another reason why I think this
material is important too many people
are saying oh you know what like Twitter
said uh yeah you know we're going to be
doing this et cetera like there you know
there's nothing new here there's not
blah blah you know it's like no seeing
the specifics really matters and and the
forced transparency often makes people
uncomfortable I think that's partly why
there was that there's been this very
there was a weird reaction when
Wikileaks first started doing this
um I think people just weren't used to
seeing that model here you know again uh
Elon Musk is
allowing this stuff to come out and he
has his own reasons for to do that but
that doesn't mean that we can't look and
be interested at the underlying material
I want to bring up this one comment
um that uh uh from hive G the FBI was
having daily meetings with Twitter and
requested that it be taken down I
believe Zach hasn't seen all the
evidence of this fact uh I have seen all
the evidence of this fact I want to get
to that uh but it there it brings up one
other point about the laptop situation I
wanted to raise which was that uh there
were intelligence officials at the time
you know assigning an open letter and
saying like this is probably
um you know Russian distance not that
it's probably it is definitely I mean
they were not leaving a lot of weasel
room you know for that yeah so I I found
you know that was very creepy that that
happened and that certainly you know I
would think had an effect on their
internal decision making that you have
these um intelligence officials doing
that
um but we are going to dig into that
relationship as we get deeper into the
Twitter files but the the next batch
that was dropped here was from Barry
Weiss
which she titles Twitter's secret
blacklists and uh there's this concept
of Shadow Banning that was you know
rumored for a long time where you would
get de-ranked but nobody would tell you
that you your tweets were hidden or
being you know throttled turns out that
pretty much has been happening
um and I think it's best exemplified by
this tweet uh Stanford's J bhattacharya
whom we've both uh interviewed uh who
argued that the coveted lockdowns would
harm children Twitter secretly placed
him on a Trends blacklist which
prevented his tweets from trending and
you can see this uh screenshot which is
the Twitter back end and it shows that
they have all these kind of built-in
tools and buttons that they can just
press to say like okay this person
shouldn't be really seen anymore uh what
was your reaction to seeing someone like
uh bhattacharya subject to this
you know again this is fantastic
information to have because we know you
know Twitter introduced you know
originally it did not have a kind of
ranking algorithm or anything people's
tweets just appeared chronologically
depending on who you fi uh followed and
things like that and by the way as a
side note it's fascinating to me how
many people in the media that I've
talked to who never even realized that
Twitter had kind of changed or that you
could go back to a chronological listing
of Tweets in your account or just go
with the algorithm and many people I
know just trust the algorithm instead of
doing uh you know a kind of
chronological listing of the people you
follow and whatnot
but I think this is really important
because it's and it's not that Twitter
shouldn't be doing this I mean I believe
you know I believe two things and
somebody like Mike masnick at techtirt
you know who's been critical he was
critical of me in a tweet when I was
talking about how good the Twitter files
were he's like come on Nick you're you
know you're uh you know you're falling
for this
um you know it's really important to see
specific examples of how this content
moderation Works
um even as I acknowledge and you know
welcome content moderation because I
don't want to have to sift through
everything I want more filters and I
also recognize as Mike masnick has you
know written about brilliantly that
content moderation at scale is like
[ __ ] impossible like it is not going
to work very well
um so I think seeing the specific tools
and understanding that and looking at
particular cases which are also you know
this is this was about covid and it's by
a guy who is a legit you know I don't
even want to say legitimate I mean but
like Jay bhattacharya is you know is
somebody's whose voice should be heard
in debates and discourse about things
like covid and pandemic policy so
um and in a lot of ways I mean I think
everybody should be you know it's but
you know that's a that's a different
measure but like to see how these two
what these tools are how they're being
enacted what they do and then like who's
subject to them it's fascinating it is
and that the point about the impossible
impossibility or unfeasibility of
content moderation at scale is something
worth talking about a little bit more
and I I think we we will talk about it a
little bit more when we start talking
about you know what could alternatives
to uh kind of the current assumptions
look like but with with regards to what
happened to barachari I agree that you
know transparency again is what I'm
hoping comes out of this that's kind of
what uh Elon Musk has hinted at a little
bit of like uh if we're going to derank
maybe we'll make it a little bit more
clear
it's not entirely clear what what Elon
Musk wants but we'll talk about that
more later but I think that the that
people that are downplaying this and
saying well everyone already knew about
it is is a little bit of a rewriting of
history I mean people have been sharing
this article as a kind of rebuttal uh
because this is from 2018. it's a slate
article says Twitter will start hiding
tweets that quote detract from the
conversation
um and Twitter had you know unrolled a
policy saying that they were going to
engage in this practice of hiding a
user's tweets from search results and
public conversations until their
reputation improves and they won't know
that they're being muted in this way
yeah
um what people are pointing to this as
evidence that uh oh this is nothing
everyone already knew this or kind of
missing is that the way Twitter was
explaining this at the time and it's
it's in this article says that less than
one percent of accounts make up the
majority of accounts reported for abuse
and so it's kind of framed as you know
these are people that are uh throwing
insults racial slurs stuff like that not
um a Stanford uh Economist and health
Professor or medical school Professor
talking about whether or not lockdowns
are Justified so I think that at the
very least we can all see there's been
some significant Mission creep uh and
and to me that's that's kind of the
point of like why we should be skeptical
of these tools is they always start off
sounding like they're going to go after
this targeted group of people this all
started going you know after Isis
accounts
um and now it ends with taking uh Jay
Pottery off or you know Shadow Banning
jaybody area yeah and of course there's
that whole you know kind of really uh
tedious semantic argument over what is
Shadow Banning or not you know
the fact that Twitter said we're going
to you know really uh content moderate
you know that's one thing and it's good
it's you know they were open semi and
saying they were going to be doing this
but you know the real thing is like what
does that actually look like in real
time and in real practice and I think
that's another reason why the Twitter
files are really important to kind of
look at and and you know appreciate
this next section of the Twitter files
gets into what's probably the most uh
contentious issue surrounding Twitter uh
for a lot of Americans the removal of
Donald Trump
um and this was this was kind of spread
across three different threads one from
taibi one from Barry Weiss and one from
Michael schellenberger
um and uh taibi kind of is sets the
stage here saying that you know even
before January 6 happened there was
already a range of visible and invisible
tools to rein in Trump's engagement and
so that's you know along the lines of
what we just talked about with this kind
of secret uh d-ranking that was being
applied heavily to Trump and he provides
lots of documentation of that such as
this uh internal communication about
Twitter Executives announcing a new L3
3D amplification tool that people might
remember you know during the height of
all this during the election you would
see you know every single Trump treat
would get a label put on it well it
wasn't just labels the labels usually
were indicating that there was some sort
of you know visibility and and I weren't
able to retweet it and like it and that
sort of thing
um
and then the mechanics of like
why did Trump actually get de-platformed
um and this is apparently the offending
tweet the 75 million Great American
Patriots who voted for me uh will have a
giant voice long into the future tweeted
Trump they will not be disrespected or
treated unfairly in any way shape or
form
um 75 million is uh rounding up a little
bit on on the vote totals by about eight
hundred thousand
but um uh so less than uh so Twitter
employees determined that his the Tweet
was not in violation of Twitter policy
but then uh uh Vijaya Gaddy Twitter's
head of legal uh policy and Trust asked
whether it could be coded incitement to
further violence and then that was kind
of there's discussions back and forth
and they kind of decided Well if you
interpret the phrase American Patriots
to refer to the rioters who went into
the capitol on January 6 then yeah maybe
this is like riling them up to try it
again or something like that so a pretty
thin read to I mean my interpretation
this is just they wanted Trump off uh
and it's kind of understandable why they
would at that point uh and they just
kind of groped for something that kind
of made sense but not really no and you
know it's uh to stick with kind of
religious metaphors and you know that
point to texts you know in order to
decide something the uh the books in the
Bible that the Catholic Church uses to
justify indulgences which aren't in the
Luther Bible or subsequent Protestant
ones but it's like when you read the
phrase you're like what what is that you
know like it doesn't directly make any
sense or make any real reference to
purgatory and indulgences this reminds
me of that where it's like you will be
searching for a long time to find the
the type of incitement to violence like
a real threat
um you know so this is you know
results-based kind of spelunking
um and exclamation of the text and again
that's why it's good to look at what's
actually going on and Twitter obviously
you know Elon Musk is you know both
hated and loved by certain elements in
the company and in the media and all of
that but it's like this is a you know
this is a public service to air this
kind of laundry I think because it will
help Twitter be better and it will help
us be better more critical consumers as
well as arguing more about like what is
good or bad policy to me it would almost
be better if they just said it's bad for
our business to have Trump on the
platform with at that and you can like
it or not but that's what we just like
that that almost get over it what Elon
Musk is doing at this point you know he
kicked uh yay off off the platform for
posting an image of a star of David with
a swastika inside of it uh which is
horrible but not you know a violation of
what what he's saying what he wants
which is just totally unbridled free
speech he's not letting Alex Jones on
there because uh he finds it disgusting
that Alex Jones you know spread
conspiracy theories and so I don't know
Elon Musk is not really putting forward
any sort of like rigorous rules-based
um like reason for a lot of his
decisions but there's almost something a
little bit uh refreshing about yeah of
just saying like yeah you know and I run
Twitter maybe we've got you know like
broad parameters but then I'm the
deciderer you know and I'm just you know
depending on my blood sugar level and my
mood or something I'm you know you're in
or you're out
um which you know is its own nightmare
you know kind of possible nightmare
future but
um yeah it's better than being gaslit
right where it's like oh well we have
strict rules that we follow in a process
and then you find out it's all being
made up
um Barry Weiss just you know just to
underscore the point about this being a
little arbitrary if you try to apply any
consistent standard to it she posted
screenshots from other leaders who had
posted things that are much clearer
violent threats you know calling Israel
a malignant cancerous tumor from uh
Ayatollah Khomeini of Iran
um there's some other examples she threw
up there
um and then this this from taigibi was
the thing that I I strongly agreed with
uh you know he says that the company was
engaged in an inherently insane slash
Impossible Project trying to create an
ever-expanding ostensibly rational set
of rules to regulate every conceivable
speech situation that might arise
between humans
um to me that pretty much Nails it that
that's what has been bothering me about
Twitter's approach and not just Twitter
but
um kind of the the big social media
companies
after Trump's election there was this
turn and it became uh there was like no
end point in sight from from my
viewpoint like once you start down this
path how do you stop and to me that is a
lot of what uh the Twitter files is
revealing is there there wasn't really a
break or a stopping point and uh let me
uh point to uh one of the questions or
uh somebody who made a starred comment
it's uh solo Dodge uh conspiracy that S
Class suppress a team uh writes a
two-part question do you think Twitter's
testimony in Congress was inaccurate
enough to qualify as lying under oath
and do you think Twitter's actions would
qualify as violating terms of service on
there and you know the answer to both of
those questions the first one is yes
because anytime you talk to uh you know
talk to Congress you are lying like they
can figure out a way to say that you're
lying to them so that's one of the
reasons you should really never talk to
Congress without a lawyer present and
probably even then
um but that's neither here nor there and
the same thing with the terms of service
maybe but like you know these are
um you know we don't want to become
super legalistic on a certain level but
like yeah there's there's a lot to talk
about here for sure I mean the testimony
before Congress was kind of a denial of
the practice of Shadow Banning which
they justify by saying well Shadow
Banning is actually making it so you
can't see the person's tweets at you
know that they do get into this kind of
legalistic uh defense because they're
like well they Define it in a way where
they're not
there's no way you can see the tweets
but you can actually see the tweets if
you go to this person's profile and like
scroll down and look for them so you
know the yeah the legal question I I
think you're right on that the kind of
like sense that there was a strong
misleading I think that is uh
unambiguously yes they yeah and I'm just
kind of point out Kevin Kerr as who
watches the Watchers and you know that's
like it's all of us this is you know
it's participatory media uh
participatory culture you know the world
is so it's all fan fiction now you know
and we all have the ability maybe not
the legal right or the kind of moral
right or cultural right to you know make
our own Adventures but it's like it's
all of us man you know that's just the
way it is yeah and uh you know that
there's that the the feature that uh we
talked about with Robbie Suave when he
was on here uh formerly known as bird
watch now known as Community notes and
that's uh kind of a shift towards well
yeah the the crowd is gonna kind of
watch the Watchers so when somebody puts
up a tweet that is questionable uh in
its uh veracity then instead of having
you know this kind of cabal of uh
hand-picked institutions fact check it
you can have any number of this
community jump in write a fact check uh
provide the sources and then the
community can you know the the demos can
vote on like you know how how accurate
was this fact check I find that I find
the sort you know the crowd Source stuff
on Twitter I find it really interesting
and useful I think it's a positive uh
kind of development but it is also funny
you know uh Zach like or I mean you know
in the Arts everybody was talking about
the wisdom of crowds you know crowds
were great betting markets were great
anything that aggregated you know you
know dispersed information it was Hayek
and it was beautiful and now it's like
no crowds our mobs you know that
occasionally break into the capital or
something said we seem to be kind of off
uh you know the wisdom of mobs right now
but that'll you know I I'm sure this is
cyclical and it will come back just
wanted to point out fist of etiquette
Who haunts all dimensions of reason it's
presence online uh writes the lesson
when launching your tech company bacon
some controls on Mission Creep from
future functionaries it's like yeah and
uh
yeah yes but it's like you never know
you know you never know what's coming
down the pike in a lot of ways yeah
although you know this was kind of the
the Insight of the uh cypherpunks which
uh we can kind of get to a little bit
later when we start talking about the
Jack Dorsey vision of Twitter is that
you have to actually design the tools
with kind of the worst actors in mind so
that they cannot be harnessed for those
ends because uh if you design it where
it it can be controlled eventually it's
going to be controlled by someone who
really shouldn't be there and I'm just
running through uh another question that
we had started in the back end of stream
yard Ethan Whittaker asks is this any
different than the world of newspaper
Supremacy in which the Barons were happy
to block stories for political friends
the rest of the internet is still there
you know uh I think it's uh worth
thinking about that I mean it's
analogous I think some of the things
that are different is that
um you know if you take social media and
kind of the people who launch these
companies and launch these platforms at
face value they are saying we are going
to be different we are not going to be
our parents or grandparents we're going
to be more open we're going to be more
transparent uh you know that's the the
coin of the realm and um so there's a an
extra charge of hypocrisy going on and I
also think you know another thing that I
find very valuable in the Twitter files
is you know kind of revealing the ways
in which control is hidden you know
um and or you know we will get into this
too I guess in a little bit but the fact
that you know Jay bhattacharya or all of
us didn't know when we were being
de-prioritized or de-ranked or whatever
um you know and and I hate people who uh
you know say oh you know I used to get a
lot of Twitter traffic or a lot of
retweets and then I didn't I'm being
Shadow banned it might be you're just
not interesting anymore but it would be
nice to be able to know you know what's
going on and the fact that Twitter and
other social media platforms hide that
or obfuscate that is you know that's a
black mark on their on their name yeah
and kind of back to what I was saying
before about uh you know Elon Musk uh
sometimes governing based just on what
seems like his personal whim that seems
like kind of a throwback to uh what what
the commenter there is talking about uh
where you know okay yes this uh this
Baron with a certain agenda and point of
view is running things but we all know
that and accept that and we can read the
paper and kind of take that for what
it's worth and I think that's kind of
what Twitter is going to transform into
it's not you know the perfect ideal
situation but maybe that is actually
somewhat of an approve Improvement uh
upon what we've uh been dealing with uh
this is just another
tweet from Michael schellenberger on the
the Trump uh suspension
um and I think that this shows uh
somebody sharing a screenshot uh of one
of Trump's
um disallowed tweets uh and it's being
critical of the screenshot saying oh my
God even Twitter says this is inciting
violence and the people the uh Twitter
employees are saying well the screenshot
is banned so we got to bounce this tweet
off of here
um and then there's some more discussion
about kind of the philosophy behind that
but uh I I don't know that was just kind
of uh alarming to me just the fact that
they're you know kind of in an automated
way
monitoring like the sharing of
screenshots and commentary on like real
historical material like that you can't
even have a discussion about things that
we all agreed happen
um that is just another example of kind
of sliding down
um a slope that I I think we should be
trying to get off of as quickly as we
can yeah I absolutely agree and it
points to that impossibility of content
moderation and regulation like you know
once you start to censor you know you
end up you know hacking off parts of
your own body in the pursuit of some
kind of purist uh you know environment
taibi is here talking about this gets
into the issue that one of the
commenters raised earlier about the
relationship between federal law
enforcement and Twitter and clearly uh
you'll Roth the uh head of uh trust and
safety at Twitter was having these
weekly meetings with uh the FBI
um here he says uh he's kind of
uh jokingly saying oh I have a very
boring business meeting that is
definitely not about Trump definitely
not meeting with FBI I swear there's
evidence here that he was also meeting
weekly with DHS and even the office of
the Director of National Intelligence
and um this kind of Harkens back to the
topic that we covered with Robbie Suave
a couple of weeks ago about these uh the
The Intercept article that that showed
um you know
like Facebook for instance I'd created a
special portal for law enforcement to go
in and Report stuff that it doesn't like
and so yeah there's clearly established
at this point a to me uncomfortably cozy
relationship and uh that I think the key
word and the concept of this stream is
like well transparency we need to know
about this stuff like right maybe there
are times when there's a legitimate
reason for the FBI to be alerting a
social media company about something but
just having this kind of secret back
door or this these back channels where
who knows what kind of like de facto
policies they're implementing makes me
very uncomfortable and does not strike
me as something that we want happening
on like our largest like online
discourse platforms and you know I I
agree with you completely and there's
you know the flip side of it is like
come on grow up you know there are bad
people in in the world and the
government you know is going to be you
know honestly and openly or and secretly
pursuing you know sharing information
that might help people uh et cetera I
don't know how far I can take that
argument I apologize
um in New York and there's uh siren in
the background there but um
like one one
um
you know uh
one solution that was proposed that I
thought was interesting came from Alex
Stamos who's a former security officer
uh technology security officer at
Facebook now runs a kind of cyber
security Institute at Stanford
um and he said let's Steel Man Elon
musk's concern about political influence
on content decisions on the major
platforms here's some practical steps
you could take commit to releasing all
Communications by global political
actors related to content moderation and
that would include governments and also
parties uh political parties and
candidates and organizations like the EU
all that we should be able it it would
make me as a consumer and someone who's
interested in you know maintaining free
discourse that would put me much more at
ease if there was a system to be able to
see what's going on and scrutinize like
are they taking things too far are but
the problem is this has all been
happening in the in the shadows kind of
and only now really coming to light I I
think you know there's also like a
disclosure is great and everything but
then once you start to say okay
disclosure is mandatory you know a
couple things happen one then you start
penalizing people for not disclosing in
the proper way and you know this happens
with campaign Finance laws where you
know you have to register this and that
and then people start getting you know
it's always the smaller people who get
uh screwed over by regulations and
regimes like that and pay fines or go to
jail but then the other thing is that
you you know you lose information in a
flurry of disclosures and you know the
the Avalanche of stuff that you have to
sift through I I don't disagree with the
impulse for that but I think you know in
the end and this is something I've been
uh fairly consistent on I think
throughout the digital age which is that
you know in the end we have to be each
individual reader has to be their own
[ __ ] detecting unit you know and
it's like every time you read we have to
radically up our game in terms of media
literacy to constantly be factoring
through the stuff and then we also
generate trusted sources you know and
and different people will trust
different sources based on you know
various criteria some people might use
reason as their filter or their
algorithm for what's important other
people will use propublica other people
will use Wikipedia you know and that's
actually not a bad thing to just have a
proliferation of filters but there's
limits to you know what any policy or
procedure can do because there's just so
much information if I may I wanted to uh
bring up and I I might have just lost
him uh but there was a
so a Critic of us in the uh here's uh
Jared Gorski uh who was saying that uh
you know we're going to start changing
goal posts and stuff I think it's a
little bit related to this where he's
saying you know uh private companies can
do what they want which is an argument
that a lot of reason people use uh
formerly deployed against people
suspicious of government censorship by
proxy now completely abandoned in fact
Elon Musk is a newspaper Baron I think
Jared Gorski is wrong he's tormenting
the things that you just said but he's
also like I know I've been consistent of
saying private you know these platforms
are private companies they can do what
they want with very broad
impunity and legal immunity but we also
have the right to complain you know like
this is I remember talking about this
early on on the recent Roundtable a lot
of like we have a right of exit which
means if you don't like something you
just go somewhere else but we also have
a Rite of voice and it's really
important that we do that like I like
Twitter I've spent a lot of time I've
helped Twitter you know grow because I
spend a [ __ ] a lot of amount of time
I create a lot of content there I
comment on things and it's like if they
were a restaurant and they stopped
serving my favorite meal I wouldn't just
be like oh well you know whatever I
would talk to the owner I would say like
you know why did you change your menu or
why don't you think about this or what's
going on or why don't you you know I'm
one of your best customers and I'm
leaving unless you put this back on the
menu so I don't think we're doing
anything different this is yeah you know
social media platforms are private
platforms and they are open for critique
and like you know that's how a free and
open Society works you know people have
exit they have voice they have also have
loyalty if we're using Albert
hirschman's uh Trifecta of the ways that
you uh respond to uh organizations and
decline in his book Exit voice and
loyalty but so Jared uh thank you for
commenting but you're wrong absolutely
and and I think he might actually be
misinterpreting what I'm saying and you
can feel free to comment again Jared if
I'm getting this wrong but I I do
believe private companies can do what
they want broadly speaking as long as
they're not you know violating other
people's rights
and that that includes you know not
having a transparent
um system of their their dealings with
uh law enforcement uh you know I think
your point was uh sound Nick that we
don't want these things to be mandated I
think what Stamos was recommending
earlier was you know volunteer Twitter
voluntarily uh published this stuff
right if we're going to talk about
mandates I actually think it should be
on the other side of the Ledger that the
FBI and DHS should have to publicly you
know post any of these kind of
interactions or requests that they make
of social media companies I think that
would make more sense from a legal
perspective but then uh it completely
abandoned in favor of Elon Musk as a
newspaper Baron what I was saying is
that you know to the degree he's acting
like a newspaper Baron or kind of like
you know the Emperor of Twitter my word
goes I'm saying I'm okay with that it's
not uh ideal it's not kind of the the
ultimate you know the apotheosis of what
I would like to see social media be calm
but um it is it is what it is he's he's
allowed to do that he's allowed to make
his own calls uh even when they don't
necessarily make sense to me and he is
also uh where we're allowed to criticize
him he's allowed to get checked by his
own Community notes and and to the
degree that he is trying to you know
Institute some additional transparency I
I think that's a good thing but that
that might be a good point for us to
start talking about well what might be
some positive developments we would like
to see
in social media in the future that that
would that might be able to mitigate
some of these
um these concerns around centralized
control of speech whether that is the uh
control exerted by the government or
their their influence on this
bureaucracy
um or even you know the newspaper Baron
uh the Twitter Baron uh Elon Musk
um my uh
uh I I create a video
um right after Trump's uh suspension
from Twitter called how to fight
de-platforming
decentralized so let's play just an
excerpt from that and then we can uh
kind of finish up our discussion
um on that topic Erica neither realities
are that was New York Times yeah reboot
that
does America need that realities are
that was New York Times Tech columnist
Kevin roos's suggestion for how the
Biden Administration could help solve
the so-called reality crisis facing the
country the chaotic events of January
6th marked the beginning of a new era of
online content moderation not only did
every major social media company kick
Trump off their platforms but Amazon web
services which owns about a third of the
global cloud storage Market evicted to
Twitter competitor parlor and Apple and
Google removed it both Democrats and
Republicans want Washington to have more
influence over how big tech companies
operate and there's a bipartisan push to
repeal section 230 of the communications
decency act known as the internet's
First Amendment that's a pretty
foundational love the the modern that's
right it's internet exactly right and it
should be revoked which would give the
government more power to hold social
media companies liable for the content
that appears on their platforms but the
great D platforming of 2021 has also
energized the movement to bring a new
radically decentralized internet that
would allow users to escape whatever
form the realities are takes
so this has been a drum that I've been
beating for a while now is the need uh
to kind of decentralize the very
infrastructure that a lot of this is
based upon so that we don't have to
worry so much about these big
bureaucratic institutions being swayed
or co-opted by the government I think
that's a way to safeguard that and that
a lot of that has really started to
emerge
um and and I think it's also in line
with uh what Twitter's founder uh
himself wants um this uh this blog post
that Jack Dorsey posted
um you know called it's kind of like his
his Manifesto in a way he calls for
social media to be resilient to
corporate and government control only
the original author may remove content
they produce uh and moderation is best
implemented by algorithmic choice I know
you read this entire post as well Nick
what's your reaction to What dorsey's
putting forward yeah I'll also uh add
you know in that same essay he talked
about how uh you know his primary
mistake when he was running Twitter was
that he focused too much on creating
tools for the Twitter bureaucracy to
Monitor and regulate content rather than
giving it to end users to create the
world you know the feeds that they
wanted I'm going to say something real
quick about the whole realities are like
we need a reality tsar of course in uh
some [ __ ] idiot from The New York
Times is going to say that because they
figure they will get to dictate and
determine and Define reality but the
fact of the matter is like we're living
in a Libertarian Paradise
um in that we all have more power to
Define reality as we see it and you know
there's going to be a lot of arguments
about that because you're in my or you
know realities are different and you
know you and I get along pretty much you
know probably 99 of the time you know
when you get more and more people and
you have 330 million people who can
start articulating and expressing their
reality
that's such a win for human freedom and
Innovation and Liberty and everything
that you want you don't want a czar
dictating what is reality and then
shoving it down the throat of people who
disagree what you want is a political
and cultural and economic system that
allows for people who disagree to do so
peacefully I mean that's the whole
project of the you know of classical
liberal and of certain kinds of
Enlightenment uh values where decisions
get decentralized from the king or the
you know the the uh the the supreme
leader down to individuals who are given
you know vast new abilities to kind of
make choices about how they want to live
and what they think is important you
know do they want to worship God which
God Etc so like this whole conversation
in a way is screwed up because what
we're trying to do is to take everything
that is good and great about the current
moment and pathologize and say we've got
a relative I think that's you know
something we should think about and then
when you look at you know what what does
that mean I you know I think Jack Dorsey
is the most thoughtful and um and
convincing and Visionary of like the
major Tech CEOs and I agree with him
broadly the one thing I would say and to
use act two is uh you know we want to
decentralize we want to decentralize
decision making we you know we want to
give people let people opt into Twitter
filters that are put together by the
ACLU or AARP or you know or AAA you know
and you just say hey I want their vision
of the world and that's how I'm going to
consume something you know that's great
that's an algorithmic choice that I
think Dorsey is talking about but when
we get to decentralization it's also
true there are costs to that which means
that it is harder for people to find
your information it is harder to build a
community or grow a community
um and that might be good you know you
want tighter communities where people
really don't just opt in by clicking a
button but actively help to construct
and modify the meaning and the growth of
a community but Twitter you know Twitter
is a mass medium in a lot of ways even
if there's a lot of individual choice
that goes into it and so
decentralization is good centralization
or a large audience has some real power
to it I know a lot of friends of mine
who are liberal to Progressive who are
you know hundreds of thousands of
followers if not over millions of
followers and they don't like Elon Musk
they wish they could leave Twitter but
they all say the same thing which is I'm
sticking here until the audience
disappears and it's going to be hard to
grow an audience of a million people a
million followers on Mastodon or on
mines or on you know various other more
distributed uh kind of platforms yeah I
mean I think that the the network
effects are are powerful and there
there's always going to be that appeal
of reaching that that mass audience that
that you know something like Twitter may
always play a role for one important
aspect of decentralization is really
decentralizing like I like online
identity is a big part of it like can
you know we you have all these followers
that you've accumulated on Twitter but
if Twitter nukes your account then
that's all gone you got to start over on
uh Mastodon or mines or parlor whatever
you know ideological like Cruise chamber
you can like uh fit into but uh if you
can you know what what Jack Dorsey wants
to do here
um is with this this uh at protocol is
kind of like the culmination of this
project that he started with blue sky is
to allow your digital identity and all
the people who you've connected to with
it to be portable and interoperable and
he wants it to make it you know an
actual protocol of the internet that you
can uh you know similar to email where
um you know once you have uh you know
um that that it's it's connected uh this
is like uh the same the same argument
that people make for uh Bitcoin is a
sort of sovereignty over your own
digital assets so you know as long as I
have the uh code uh
um to access my Bitcoin that's mine no
Central Authority can do anything they
want to do the same thing with identity
and um that is a vision while not fully
realized at this point that is
compelling to me I I will say and there
is an irony that Mastodon which is
trying to
um I think uh bootstrap that into
existence is sort of getting a boost
from Elon Musk taking over Twitter to
try to make it a more more of a free
speech platform but now all the people
who think that Elon Musk is you know
allowing all this garbage on the
platform are the ones
uh going over to Mastodon and so it's
this weird self-selected group
um but you know the the interesting like
concept about Mastodon is that uh it is
you can choose kind of your own
moderation from what I understand I
haven't uh joined Mastodon but I believe
you have what's your experience you know
I got to tell you I and I'm like fairly
Tech forward uh you know I'm I'm not
pretending I'm a genius computer
engineer or anything but like you know
I'm I've been online for 30 plus years
and I like trying out new stuff Mastodon
is complicated and off-putting
um and that's a problem you know in the
same way that like you know when you try
to Mint or or sell or buy an nft on open
C it hasn't reached the level of user
friendliness yet that is going to really
make it you know a mass thing which in
some ways is the charm there are lots of
just first places to go to have
audiences and create them you know
because and you know and there are
Discord servers there are you know
Telegram and signal and WhatsApp groups
and even Facebook which BR you know
cracks down on groups you can live in
you know these what used to be called
temporary autonomous zones you know
where nobody can stop you nobody can
watch you
Etc but you know the temporary
autonomous sense which was a very
popular Concept in the 90s as the
internet and cyberspace was being built
out it's important to recognize that
they're temporary that you know what you
want at the beginning of something what
you want when you are creating a
settlement on the frontier may not be
what you want in 10 years when the
population has grown by you know 50
times or something like that
um so I think one of the other problems
with a lot of our discourses that we
expect each thing to be everything and
it's you know what and Dorsey two years
ago at the Bitcoin conference in Miami
he said you know he wants Twitter to be
one of you know a hundred or an infinite
number of social media platforms and
messaging platforms and some of those
will be completely decentralized other
ones not et cetera but that's you know
like Twitter can't be all things to all
people
um and I think it serves a function it
has served a function it's changing over
time
um but it you know it's not going to be
everything and for certain things you're
going to want to go to Mastodon or to
you know a kiwi Farms or like some other
you know kind of ultra message board and
recognizing that is helpful because you
don't want all platforms to be governed
by all the same rules
um you know you want people to be able
to invent whatever they want and use it
in that way
um I know you have to run soon Nick so
let's uh finish up on with uh this
question I think can bring us into kind
of a final topic uh D under Reiner says
how do you all feel about musk kicking
the guy who tracks his jet off Twitter
uh that would be Elon jet uh which was
an account that I guess took publicly
available flight data and just told
everyone you know where's Elon Musk
going next
um my opinion about it is again uh I'm
totally fine with Elon Musk doing
whatever he wants and feels comfortable
with on Twitter what I take exception to
is uh trying to
create some sort of universal rule out
of it that really doesn't make that much
sense so like the rule that they tried
to make because uh Elon Musk didn't like
the guy tracking his jet on Twitter is
that if someone shares an individual's
live location there's an increased risk
of fiscal harm moving forward we'll
remove tweets that share this
information and accounts dedicated to
sharing someone else's live location
will be suspended
um and then he adds you know a caveat
some caveats like um if you share
someone's past location that's okay also
information related to a public
engagement or events like a concert or
political event is also permitted It
just strikes me as you know you're
you're creating a really broad rule that
is almost certainly going to have lots
of unintended consequences to try to
deal with this one account that you
don't like
um like just some examples that come to
mind as somebody who's covered Live
Events before or is like there's a
protest that breaks out it's not a plant
political event or a public venue or
anything but it's a notable news event
you start filming it taking pictures
posting to Twitter someone doesn't like
how you're covering it so they report
the tweets to Twitter and you get them
booted off uh you know just being out at
a mall and seeing a celebrity or
something and taking a picture I mean
maybe that's maybe that is bad that that
goes on Twitter maybe celebrities
deserve more privacy but you know I I
don't like uh kind of trying the way uh
Elon Musk is in this case trying to
shoehorn his own like discomfort into
some like Universal rule yeah I agree
completely and this goes back to the
earlier discussion of you know it's it's
musk's platform he can do that if he
wants but it's kind of a stupid Rule and
it seems to be motivated by really dumb
narcissistic
egoistic you know know kind of protocols
I you know uh and you know to the extent
that that keeps happening or it becomes
larger and larger and it you know kind
of Nets more and more catches more
people in its net it's going to degrade
the experience of Twitter in a really
bad way
um you know at various points musk has
talked about
providing users on Twitter with you know
an understanding of like if you get uh
blocked or if you get de-prioritized
you'll you will be told that and you
will be given an appeals process in a
lot of ways you know I mean that would
be better than what we have but again
like you know there are billions of
users of Twitter that's a lot of people
and like the more a private business you
know they can do whatever the [ __ ] they
want but the more they they are like we
need to be Hall monitors on all sorts of
stuff like then you all you do is you
spend doing that all the time like and
it's just not good it's so much better
to say we are you know within the
broadest parameters possible you know
because we care about Free Speech we're
going to let things rip and we're going
to give you the users the ability to
filter your experience you know the way
that you want to
um you know it just seems like to me you
know but then again I'm a Libertarian
like I'm more comfortable with that and
you know in the same way at Mastodon you
can go to a community that will say you
know like no fat chicks or something you
know like whatever it is and they can
rigorously enforce whatever rules they
want in their subdivision of Mastodon
you can do that on Twitter you know or
you I mean you could do it now but maybe
if they made that more robust that would
be interesting um one final thing that
kind of is related to this I think Zach
is uh you know uh Elizabeth Nolan Brown
of Reason has a good cover story in the
new issue is called in defensive
algorithms part of what she talks about
in our colleague Robbie Suave has also
talked about this in his book techpanic
um you know places like Twitter and
Facebook and whatnot who are accused of
creating filter Bubbles and of like
putting people you know where people you
know can withdraw from this supposed
mass media world that we existed five
minutes ago where we were forced to
engage people we didn't agree with like
it turns out you know that Twitter and
Facebook and most social media are
platforms you know as they existed 15
minutes ago facilitate a lot more
crossover
um compared to traditional forms of
media so
you know I don't know like but I I think
you know letting more people speak more
freely on Twitter would be good for
Twitter it would be good for society and
just give users more ability to filter
out the crap they don't want which might
be because of hate speech or ideology or
just like I'm not interested in pictures
of people holding up fish
you know that they caught or something
yeah uh we got a super chat here for ten
dollars uh thank you tune in and drop
out Elon didn't remove the guy tracking
his location until he started receiving
death threats and and yeah there and
there was also an issue where someone
showed up was uh like I think followed
one of his cars and his uh young
daughter was in there so yeah I have no
um you know I certainly have sympathy
for the idea that you know someone of
that stature is having to deal with all
sorts of stuff that none of us would
want to deal with
um and that you know there might be a
reason he wouldn't want his own platform
to uh have an account like that uh my
objection really is to again the idea
that uh this uh
that some sort of uh rule can be like
rational rule I mean maybe a rule could
be crafted around it that would make
sense but what he put forward I don't
think makes that much sense and is a
little broad but maybe that could bring
us to our our final uh points to make
because we need to wrap up here
um which I think let's just talk about
you know how do we feel about Elon Musk
taking over Twitter um and I can start
because I uh I uh when he first made the
offer I released a video uh called uh
Elon Musk as a wild card good uh and I
and I still feel that way I I think that
um you know I have
there's a lot of uncertainty about what
he's going to do with Twitter
um it's still not entirely clear to me
what his motivations Beyond you know
turning a profit are for Twitter but um
I think that the situation that has been
further illuminated by the Twitter files
was becoming untenable and that Twitter
needed a shake up it needed a reboot I
don't know if Elon Musk is going to in
fact I would bet uh good money that he's
not going to take it in exactly the
direction that I would want it to be
taken but uh just having uh it taken in
a radically different direction having
somebody who says I don't want all of
this uh waiting going on of certain
political opinions over other political
opinions
um even if it might be hard to implement
his vision the fact that he's going to
try I think is a good thing the fact
that some people are migrating to
Mastodon and maybe that will give other
social media sites a kick in the pants
that's a good thing I think it was time
for shake up uh that that's what's great
about
um you know the the digital age and
about the age of social media is these
things can be reinvented new things can
uh crop up despite what uh politicians
on the left and right want to tell you
these aren't uh you know immovable
monopolies that need to be uh regulated
or like held liable for every little
thing that goes on them
um there can be disruption and we're
seeing that right now and and for that
reason I still am generally in favor of
uh the the musk acquisition and I'm glad
it happened yeah like you uh about a
year and a half ago I created a video at
reason uh uh you know it's on our
YouTube channel five ways Elon Musk and
other billionaires get welfare for the
rich and I I'm not a uh Elon Musk you
know uh true love type of person I think
he's phenomenal some of the companies
and some of the products and services
he's created are fantastic I like you
I'm I'm glad that he took over Twitter
um which everybody agreed you know like
before he even tendered an offer people
were talking about how Twitter is a
hellscape blah blah blah you know so
it's like it I mean this is you know the
problem with a lot of political
discourse is that it just is so [ __ ]
dumb and short-sighted so somehow
Twitter which was a garbage you know
fire uh before must to cover is really
bad now and uh we can't take it you know
this is just stupid I think it needed to
be shaken up I think one of my critiques
of musk is it even anything like
specific that he's doing but Twitter
definitely needs a full-time CEO this is
a you know a service with billions of
users and Twitter was dying on the vine
for I would say dying on the vine you
know when Twitter bought Vine
and kind of Incorporated that as well as
Periscope even before that a live
streaming platform like they they have a
track record of having bought really
interesting or developed interesting
services and then not done anything with
them I attribute that to the fact that
Jack Dorsey you know who was out and
then back in for a long time his
attention is was very divided Elon
musk's attention is very divided so
apart from anything else I just wish
Twitter would get a good CEO who would
focus on it because it is a great
platform it's really interesting it has
given me and I think literally billions
of other people over the over its
lifetime a lot of enjoyment a lot of
anger it's done really good stuff I
don't think it's done particularly
Terrible Things
um you know uh and so like it's it's a
it's a real asset and I want it to
flourish
um you know and I think it'll flourish
better under musk than what it was you
know six months ago but that unless it
has somebody's full attention it's going
to kind of uh it's it's not going to
reach its full potential
and uh the in an interesting uh aspect
of kind of the corporate structure of
Twitter is uh you know it Jack Dorsey in
that essay we referenced earlier talks
about how once they went public uh and
some activists shareholders got involved
he really got sidelined in terms of
implementing his vision
um and so that's you know these the way
things these deals are structured seems
to have a huge effect on how it all
plays out that that maybe is underrated
and the fact that Elon Musk took it
private has a lot more autonomy to do
what he want I mean I take your point
that his attention might be uh too
divided but maybe that alone will uh you
know make a big difference in terms of
being able to engage in some creative
destruction that's a positive I I think
you're right and that it's a great Point
um you know to go back to your analogy
of uh you know like the Press Barons or
your invocation of them in the past
of newspaper owners there is you know in
publishing there is a critique of like
billionaire owners that um Jack uh
Schaefer at politica the media critic
there uh has written about for you know
going on 50 years now but that what
happens uh you know uh you know when
Chris Hughes who had been a big wig at
Facebook took over the new Republic they
buy it you know they buy it for a while
and they're going to change everything
and they're going to do it and it's
their baby and then they get bored with
it
um and they kind of cast it aside this
happened to the Atlantic which went from
David Bradley who was big on something
else you know and he ran it for a long
time but he cut you know passed it off
to Steve Jobs widow
um you know who will go through a phase
this happens to a lot of publishing
Outlets you know whether they're old
print magazines or you know uh online
platforms and um I worry about that a
little bit but you know fundamentally
what's good is that disruption
Innovation change can happen and I think
you're right in focusing on you know
whatever happens we'll probably will
almost certainly be better than the way
the status quo was trending so yeah I
think yeah and whatever happens uh I'll
be there to see it uh I'm on Twitter at
the bridge Zach Nick is on Twitter at
nicolespie you should follow both of us
uh the and reason at reason and then at
reason uh and uh yeah the rumors of uh
Twitter's imminent death were greatly
exaggerated it seems I remain a skeptic
that it's going down in flames anytime
soon but I want to thank uh Nick for the
conversation I think the commenters for
uh the great input and we will see you
again uh next time